bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de kiosques kiosques que
votre magazine culturel sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ses environs tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 28
novembre jusqu'au 28 février l'espace
richaud de versailles présente une
nouvelle exposition le petit prince à
versailles soixante dix ans après sa
première édition en france le petit
prince reste un phénomène éditorial
mondial avec 145 millions d'exemplaires
vendus dans le monde
guillaume le tocard vice président de
l'association food rock est en plateau
pour nous présenter de la 5e édition du
festival food rock le samedi 28 novembre
à l'estaminet de magny les hameaux
une soirée de concerts dans une ambiance
conviviale
quatre membres du groupe que shadows
copie nous rejoindrons en plateau pour
nous présenter leur groupe hommage aux
shadows et leurs dates de concert samedi
soir à la batterie de guyancourt
je vous disais jusqu'au 28 février
l'espace richesse de versailles présente
une nouvelle exposition le petit prince
à versailles soixante dix ans après la
première parution en france de cette
oeuvre
le petit prince reste un phénomène
éditorial mondial avec et 400000
exemplaires qui se vendent chaque année
tout de suite un sujet préparé avec
mélanie poquet et patrick jacques de
dixmude dessine moi un mouton
cette phrase a fait le tour du monde en
70 ans le petit prince oeuvre majeure de
saint-exupéry s'est écoulé à plus de 145
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde et
a été traduit en 270 langues conte
philosophique écrit pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale et publié en france en
1946 ont des générations dont lui et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que beaucoup
de gens l'ont vu à l'école donc et on en
une lecture scolaire mais déjà très
intéressante
et quand il se replonge des années après
pardon pour la lecture pour leurs
enfants parce qu'il le lise pour leurs
enfants eux-mêmes découvre autre chose
c'est une réflexion sur la vie
l'humanité sur soi même
est-ce qu'on a un enfant ce qu'on a un
adulte est ce qu'on peut grandir est ce
qu'on doit agrandir l'espace richaud
accueille jusqu'au 28 février une
exposition consacrée aux petits princes
en partenariat avec la succession
antoine de saint-exupéry et le musée air
france toutes les facettes du petit
prince ont décliné ainsi que les
différentes personnalités deux sont
créés
terre un personnage qui est connu de
tous donc il peut donner lieu à pour les
visiteurs à une pratique on va dire
totalement transgénérationnel c'est vrai
qu'on on a tous été baissés les bercer
par le petit prince je connais peu de
personnes qui ne le connaissent pas et
en même temps c'est un personnage qui
méritait d'être mise en lumière qu'on
explore toutes les facettes c'est ce
qu'on se propose de faire dans
l'exposition et puis aussi qu'on explore
c'est le cas d'ailleurs dans cette salle
particulièrement quand il court aussi
sont les différents visages de son
créateur de nombreuses pièces originales
issues de la collection du musée art
france et pour la plupart jamais
exposées au grand public avions
gourmette carnet de vol et agendas de
saint-exupéry ce héros de guerre disparu
en mer au large de marseille le 31
juillet 1944 lors d'un vol d'observation
à 44 ans on sait exupéry et un pour les
personnels d'air france en particulier
est un mythe est un héros et qu'il a
dessiné lui-même la voie du courage de
l'abnégation pour transporter le
courrier qui relié les skis relier les
hommes entre le petit prince a été
l'objet de nombreuses adaptations ses
rencontres avec le 9e art notamment avec
les célèbres dessinateurs hugo pratt et
joann sfar sont présentés dans une
galerie et dans la crypte le public
découvre le film d'animation le petit
prince
réalisé par mark osborne
et ses toiles se sont levés
mais au pied jouer avec moi je ne peux
pas jouer avec toi je ne suis pas pris
vos erreurs
mais si tu vas brivoise nous aurons
besoin de l'autre tu seras pour moi
unique au monde
dessine moi un mouton sans transition je
vous propose de parler rock maintenant
avec nos prochains invités en plateau
guillaume le tocard vice président de
l'association food rock bonsoir et jean
adrian programmateurs des vendredis du
rock pour versailles bonsoir bonsoir
l'exposition le petit prince une
exposition qui vous paraît que vous
comptez aller voir ben évidemment
d'autant plus que c'est à versailles
puis s'éteint dans un espace absolument
sublime et que c'est une thématique qui
est qui touche tout le monde des enfants
plus grand donc bien évidemment oui
alors on peut rêver avec le petit point
sont aussi rêver d'une autre façon
voyager diront avec la dirons-nous avec
la musique
alors guillaume le tocard vous êtes là
aujourd'hui pour nous présenter la
cinquième édition du festival food rock
qui aura lieu samedi à partir de 16h à
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire un
mot sur votre association une
association qu'on a créé en 2011
on a une vingtaine de passionnés qui
constituent cette assoc et voilà donc on
a on a monté un festival depuis depuis
2011 qu on a l'ambition de grandir donc
voilà il ya aucun permanent dans cette
association que des passionnés des
passionnés des musiciens nécessairement
ou pas forcément il ya une grande partie
de musiciens ou et oui tout à fait et
donc qu'on a on a cette volonté de
maintenir la culture rock dans les
yvelines
alors c'est un festival professionnel
c'est un festival d'amateurs comment
vous positionner là la particularité en
fait dans sa programmation d'associer
des groupes à forte notoriété qu'on
connaît tous avec des groupes en devenir
donc on fait une sélection durant
l'année pour choisir quelques petits
groupes soit de la région soit d'un peu
plus loin mais qui retiennent
l'attention et que l'on souhaite
associer avec les grands groupes
est ce que ce festival s'inscrit dans un
dans une couleur de rock particulière
non on a on a l'ambition en fait de
toucher tous les styles de rock et on
non
on a pour coutume de dire du blues
fondateur jusqu'au métal métal est un
ravageur comme comme certains le disent
donc ça touche un peu toutes les
couleurs toutes les palettes du rock
donc on a eu il ya une année deportivo
donc on va aussi bien cherché des
groupes dans des styles funk etc
donc on ouvre un peu les palettes
sonores et voilà donc dans différents
styles vous en a vraiment pour les
vendredis du rock est ce que vous axez
sur un rock plutôt calme non on est
ouvert à toutes sortes de rock et on va
même chercher parfois un peu plus loin
que le rock puisqu'on est ouvert au hip
hop au reggae ou aux tendances le lytro
après c'est vrai que la majorité des
groupes qui se présentent sont quand
même des groupes à tendance rock
après de multiples facettes dans
l'europe donc on en déficit on aime
bénéficie chaque soir de manière
différente
alors cette année votre festival a une
couleur un peu teinté on va dire hard
rock et je vous propose de regarder tout
de suite un extrait du teaser du
festival qui vous attend
non
alors guillon l'autocar quels sont les
têtes d'affiché de ce de cette émission
on vient les voir donc il ya un bukowski
qui clôturera la soirée et on a hâte
charger un groupe de caen qui est
également on peut dire en caux en
cottage affiche de ce festival
ça ce sont vraiment des identités fortes
et des personnalités qui vont attirer
alors un public d'initiés
est-ce que vous attendent également un
public plus généraliste ou pas alors on
a on a maintenant un public est fidèle
au festival est généralement où il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent découvrir
ça qu'on a entendu parler du food rock
etc et donc on voit là il ya il ya des
gens d'univers un peu différent qui est
qui viennent nous voir sans souci way
alors cette année c'est hard rock mais
l'édition précédente
on était sûr quelques couleurs on avait
deux journées donc on avait une journée
qui était on va dire stoner pour les
initiés et puis une soirée un peu plus
rock avec un one is innocent qui qui qui
jouait le vendredi alors cette année il
y a vraiment une particularité très
intéressante que vous allez nous
expliquer on va vivre une expérience
amplifié qu'est ce qu'une expérience
amplifiées tout à fait donc cette année
il ya deux start-up qui viennent et dont
une qui a augmenté l'acoustique qui va
proposer une expérience différente pour
les auditeurs site un système qui permet
d'avoir un son
avec des casques et puis des
applications sur smartphone d'avoir un
meilleur son et également de pouvoir
mixer comme on le souhaite
le concert est donc vivre différemment
ceux qui sont plutôt axés sur la guitare
pourront avoir un mix avec les guitares
plus en avant et c'est à dire contours
public sera casque et alors c'est une
expérience c'est une première expérience
donc ya pas il n'ya pas 350 ou 400 400
casques de disponible donc c'est un peu
plus petit que ça c'est une vingtaine
mais comme on a la chance d'avoir six
groupes dans la soirée les gens il ya
plusieurs groupes qui pourront passer
donc cesser c'est une première
démonstration
voilà de cette start up a augmenté de
l'acoustique sera pas mal ça pour aller
vendredi duras klein c'est un concept
très amusant fois qu'il permet
effectivement de singulariser
l'expérience l'expérience du constat ça
m'étonne pas dire qu'une structure
associative qui qui généralement ne
manquent pas d'imagination et
d'expérimentation si je poussais toute
la valeur qu'on peut reconnaître aux
valeurs associatives dans la musique se
lance dans ce type de projet mais au
delà d'être une expérience originale est
ce que vous considérez que sur le plan
musical c'est vraiment intéressant à ce
que ça apporte quelque chose je pense
que ça apporte quelque chose dans le
vêtement par rapport à l' écoute par
rapport aux sensibilités qu'on peut
qu'on peut attendre de tel ou tel
instrument de tel ou tel vocalises après
il faut pas non plus que ça vienne au
tas mais je dirais là l'expérience du
concert que quand même l'expérience
collective mais ça votre expérimentation
nous en donnera des résultats plus
certain affaire à suivre
alors guillaume l'autocar samedi c'est
aussi une date particulière parce qu'il
ya une forme d'hommage s'est rendu à
l'estaminet salle dans laquelle sera la
dernière fois que le festival prendra
ses quartiers
oui tout à fait c'est comme ça qu'on a
on a voulu la programmation c'est comme
ça qu'on a qu'on a fait les choses sont
que 2015 c'est la dernière édition à
l'estaminet donc on remercie puisque
ceux qui nous ont lancés mais la salle
devient un peu petit et 2016 donc on
peut on peut l'annoncer il y aura une
édition en plein air beaucoup plus
grandes que ce qu'on fait jusqu'à
présent très bien jean adrien ou
poursuit en vrac avec vous donc je
disais vous êtes programmateur de
vendredi du rock sur versailles la
quatrième saison s'est arrêté en avril
dernier la cinquième saison a démarré la
début novembre
ce que vous pourriez vous réexpliquer
aux concepts des vendredis du rock
là où vous savez que verser à une
histoire très particulière avec la
musique et la musique non seulement
baroque mais également le musique plus
contemporaine
vous savez la tradition contemporaine
qui s'écrit autour de la deûle à
versailles touch avec des groupes comme
le phénix alela diane ducret si alex
potter ou d'autres et il ya également
une anecdote dans l'histoire
contemporaine de versailles qu'on ne
mentionne pas assez souvent et qui
pourtant était un peu à l'image de notre
projet c'est se souvenir de 1964 dans le
cinéma du cyrano qui à l'époque était
une salle de spectacle et en 1964 il ya
eu en france premier concert des beatles
et donc c'était assez au cirano à
versailles
pourquoi les beatles sont venus à
versailles pour leur premier concert
et bien tout simplement parce que le
patron du cirano était un grand copain
de bruno coquatrix de l'olympia et
coquatrix demandé à la famille des dons
qui qui tenait qui tient encore le
cyrano d'expérimenter en fait ces
groupes sur sa scène avant qu'ils ne
viennent si l'expérience est elle est
concluante à l'olympia et donc c'est
comme ça que les beatles sont venus
jouer d'abord à versailles avant d'aller
ensuite à l'olympia et d'un autre
ambition avec les vendredis du rock
c'est celle d'être cette antichambre en
fait des grandes scènes d'être de
proposer cette première expérience à des
à des jeunes groupes talentueux en
devenir
donc ces groupes amateurs professionnels
en voie de professionnalisation dont il
ya 38 comme pointu sol est à la base de
ce qu'ils ont été présélectionnés exact
alors voilà vous avez rappelé vous avez
raison de rappeler le principe c'est à
dire qu'on a effectivement d'abord ça on
se base sur une sélection donc les
groupes postule
il ya ensuite un jury qui se réunit qui
écoute les maquettes les saint cloud et
deezer ou autres que les groupes ont
proposé dans le jury on a
essentiellement des membres de l'équipe
dès vendredi du rock qui ont la
caractéristique d'être d'avoir des
profils variés avec le à la fois des des
musiciens pur et dur d 1g sont des
des chargés de projet des gens qui
suivent le les vendredis du rhum depuis
le début alors quel est l'enjeu
particulier pour ces groupes qui se
prête au jeu
au delà bien sûr de vivre de leur
passion et partager leur art mais vous
savez j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
verse et l'itouch et c'est vrai que
c'est un un petit drame de même que des
groupes comme phoenix ou comme air se
soit fait d'abord connaître à los
angeles avant de se faire connaître à
versailles et nous ce qu'on souhaiterait
justement c'est pouvoir proposer à ces
jeunes groupes de versailles les
environs de versailles de l'ouest
parisien d'une manière générale de
pouvoir jouer chez eux tout simplement
devant leur public avant d'aller voir
avant d'aller voir plus loin
donc pour eux il ya d'abord le plaisir
tout simplement de jouer au près de chez
eux
il ya la possibilité de rencontrer
d'autres groupes qui sont dans la même
situation qu'eux donc avec vraiment une
un projet musical un projet
professionnel derrière
en tout cas la volonté de proposer la
musique la plus aboutie possible
et puis et puis donc la possibilité de
confronter à la fois en juillet puis un
public qui au fil des ans a étoffé son
oreille ça leur sert également de
tremplin exactement dans un esprit
tremplin prochaines dates vendredi 4
décembre il y aura trois groupes qui
vont se produire y aura se faisait pas
une liste pardon il y aura alphabétique
halles et le dernier c'est moonshine ou
john bost montant place alors aux
palmistes en plus c'est un groupe local
c'est un groupe versaillais et on en
regarde tout de suite un extrait
est-ce que les trois groupes
s'inscrivent dans cette même tendance de
rock un peu swing un peu folle qui n'ont
pas n'ont pas particulièrement saison
voilà on a pu écouter ses palmistes
effectivement qui penche plus vers le
folk mais quand vous écoutez
alphabétique comme vous êtes sur quelque
chose de beaucoup plus contemporain
quelque chose d'un peu plus aérien aussi
un peu plus électro que je doute très
aboutie d'ailleurs je dois dire que je
suis moi même très admiratif de
l'aboutissement de leur composition pour
le pour le plan jeune âge et puis pour
ce qui est de moudjahid glace on est sur
un rock plus plus classique que plus
rythmé et très entraînant très bien
jean adrian guillaume le tocard merci
d'avoir été en plateau avec nous et donc
je rappelle que le festival food rock ce
sera samedi à l'estaminet de magny les
hameaux à partir de 16h et le prochain
rendez vous les vendredis du rock ce
sera le 4 décembre à la salle tassin
cour à versailles pour retrouver trois
groupes donc on disait aux palmistes
alphabétique hull et moonshine blast à
partir de 20h30
et comme chaque semaine votre rubrique
cinéma
qu'avez vous pensé des films à la fille
de ce mercredi 28 novembre vous aviez au
micro de jérémy quesada ouais c'est bien
pour lui c'est bien cela montre le
niveau une chose les mauvaises choses ça
leur apprendra avoir peur mais c'est un
bon dessin animé c'est sympa et
l'histoire est pas mal
ouais c'est sentimental c'est nul ça
prend aux tripes et à la fin de la
projection je vais rester une minute
comme ça sans bouger sans pouvoir rien
faire ne rien dire c'est bon c'est sûr
plus maintenant avec son vie c'est
vraiment d'actualité c'est très
éprouvant ch et super happy qui se
couvre qu'est ce que tu lis d'appui est
génial on le reconnaît à peine
vraiment il a un rôle prochain rôle de
salomé bon il le joue bien et c'est un
très bon film de c c'est sur la peine
les italiens les irlandais mais c'est
vraiment bien
scénario bien ficelé vraiment un bon
film on a passé un bon moment
johnny dette incroyable performance
donc je conseille le jeu d'acteur de
daniel pas mal comme qui est très
intéressant et puis la fin un peu court
peut-être un petit peu course et c'est
un taux bas que j'ai trouvé d'après un
peu bâti j'ai bien aimé des effets
spéciaux sont grandioses
la seule chose que je regrette dans les
pubs médecins en 3d et on continue cette
émission avec un petit tour d'horizon
des expositions actuelles de la région
direction la maison félix à montigny le
bretonneux pour retrouver l'exposition
dirait nos moutons qui manie le faire
chaud pour travailler la cire en
peinture et de liliane briane qui
préfèrent la sculpture à l'argile et
propose un ensemble de statut féminine
des oeuvres aux couleurs vives
inspiré de différentes cités perdues
c'est une exposition présentée à la
maison félix jusqu'au 29 novembre de 14
à 18 heures en présence des artistes
dans un autre style le théâtre espace
coluche à plaisir accueille jusqu'au 9
janvier
l'exposition parallèle une exposition
d'urban art denise heures et lunaire
deux artistes originaires des yvelines
sensible à une culture street et
graffitis 89,99 pardon pour cent des
toiles de l'unr sont réalisées à la
peinture à la bombe pas de contrôle du
pinceau misr lui préfère travailler
davantage la photo autour de l'
architecture urbaine leur travail
complémentaire les a poussés à créer en
2011 le collectif matières premières on
écoute tout de suite vincent desmons
directeur du théâtre espace rouge de
plaisir qui nous en parlent de choses la
technique pour les visages où ils sont
extrêmement expressif c'est une
technique à l'aérographe qui est très
intéressante qui pourrait presque
s'inscrire dans le
dans la technique de l'hyperréalisme
cette école américaine et puis dans
l'autre artiste c'est le côté très
abstrait justement qui fait place à
l'imaginaire l'artiste devant lequel je
suis effectivement passe dépasser du
graffiti au graphisme comme ça
d'ailleurs avec des photos et même à la
photo puisque là on retrouve de forme de
son art vient de nous rejoindre en
plateau le groupe shell de skopies pour
continuer à parler rock quatre membres
du groupe ciat de skopies nous recevons
daniel biau le batteur luis leur est le
bassiste claude mas letra soliste et qui
chante et alain piffeteau noah la
rythmique et auchan messieurs bonsoir
alors tout de suite première question
c'est pourquoi jadot scoopy alain
peut-être chanot scrupules parce que
notre répertoire et surtout inspiré de
ce groupe mythique anglais shadows et
puis on a trouvé que shadow stoppie
c'était quelque chose qui sonnait bien
on se rappelle radioscopie voilà copier
coller alors oui qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que ça représente en fait the shadows
c'est une musique qui m'a toujours plu
surtout que moi je suis arrivé à
l'époque où il sortait c'était un peu
mandat d'amener sens et et si tu as he
arc ou jeu où je me plaît je me sens
bien et puis mon plus ce qu'on essaye de
retransmettre si la joie qu'on a sur
scène et on a le retour des spectateurs
c'est pour nous c'est gagner quoi alors
the shadows c'est vraiment cultissime le
rock anglais presque même le rock
mondiale la référence
daniel ça veut dire que vous n'y a que
des reprises en fait de the shadows
jeudi reprise mais calquer ses cales qui
est donc aussi que si mme pas vraiment
on joue vraiment l'original que que me
connu et claude du coup là l'a dit la
difficulté de l'exercice
dans la reprise dans le fait de ne pas
composer un autre morceau mais de
reprendre elle se situe elle se situe
nous tentons de libyens ou tentant de
reproduire tant que faire se peut donc
se sont mythiques
voilà donc ça c'est la première
difficulté ensuite vont pas les shadows
avec un panel très des traînards jeunes
parce qu'ils chantaient également bien
sûr c'était les concurrents j'allais
dire direct ils se sont trouvés en
concurrence avec les beatles en 63 et
donc ils ont été un petit peu éclipsé
par le regain d'actes il d'un intérêt
pour les beatles mais donc pour en
revenir aux difficultés va la grande
difficulté est effectivement c'est de
s'approcher autant que faire se peut
donc les dés sont ces dates sondes
quand on dit et ça devient j'allais dire
pour certains obsessionnel voyez voilà
donc alors alain querre rapport en fait
votre groupe à la musique alors une
passion ça c'est palpable
s'il est réputé vous ré pardon vous
répéter régulièrement très régulièrement
notamment dans les studios de la
batterie si accueillants tout et puis
aussi chez les uns chez les autres pour
des petites mises aux points
particulière alors que l'autre quels
sont les lieux dans lesquels vous
produisez on se produit dans des
brasseries restaurants très pris et puis
ça l'était une salle de spectacle en
fait surtout de petits concerts
d'animations dans des pubs etc
et qu'est ce que vous allez chercher
surtout à partager avec le public samedi
soir
est ce qu'il ya une difficulté
particulière vraiment des dans une salle
de concert
il ya quelque chose qui change dans la
proche ben oui parce que c'est quand
même pas la même ambiance assez on est
vraiment sur une sur une scène devant
des spectateurs
c'est quand même un gros challenge alors
oui le mode challenge lui c'est le pari
que dans une brasserie où les gens
mangent boivent
coût 38 de l'animation c'est un concert
s'adresse vraiment un public
et alors ce public est ce que c'est un
public de jeunes encore est-ce que
shadows fédère encore la jeunesse ou pas
forcément non c'est vrai c'est plutôt
les ondes et surveillants on est super
bien c'est une musique aussi qui a
inspiré pas mal de grands guitaristes
internationaux se soient tous des
artistes mondiaux mondialement connu et
donc les gens de notre génération
forcément été inspiré par ce et de même
on a commencé la musique par ce thème
quand on avait l'âge de fer des groupes
pendant nos études et vous pensez
vraiment que vous allez rester fidèles
alors à ce groupe jusqu'au bout jamais
vous n'avez envie de basculer sur un
autre style de rock ou sur un autre
groupe
non mon énergie dans le répertoire en
chantant alors que les chadoufs je sais
c'est vraiment la simmental et
maintenant on chante avec le chanteur de
déjà douze clichés très bien louis
claude alain et daniel merci d'avoir été
en plateau avec nous je rappelle que
l'on pourra vous retrouver sur la scène
de la batterie samedi soir à partir de
20h30
et avant de nous quitter je vous propose
comme chaque semaine quelques dettes
à noter dans vos agendas la 15e édition
de la fête du conte de saint quentin en
yvelines se déroule jusqu'au 5 décembre
dans toutes les médiathèques et lieux
partenaires ateliers lectures
expositions et spectacles ainsi que des
veillées autour des contes et histoires
fabuleuses prennent leurs quartiers
tout le programme sur le site du kiosque
samedi 28 novembre la ville de plaisir
organisée à la bibliothèque la mosaïque
à 15 heures une rencontre dédicaces avec
les auteurs et dessinateurs du prince de
motordu et enfin mardi 1er décembre
20h30 à la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux retrouver gérald
dahan pour son nouveau spectacle tombent
les masques et cet imposteur versatile
piégeant les hommes politiques grâce à
des canulars téléphoniques vous offrir
un show interactif où le public peut
choisir
artiste on regarde tout de suite un
extrait des fonds c'est un groupe i
ma politique aura des résultats coc je
ne sais pas je suis patient au problème
pourquoi le sort est enfin du kiosque
pour cette semaine merci de nous avoir
suivis très bonne soirée à tous